aux états unis on compte maintenant 88
morts après la série de tornades qui a
eu lieu ce week-end dans plusieurs
villes dans le centre et dans le sud du
pays parmi les victimes s'ils sont
décédées dans l'entrepôt du géant amazon
c'est une polémique qui enfle en tout
cas oui c'est dans le kentucky et les
pôles la polémique enfle justement sur
les questions de sécurité les proches
des victimes dénonce des manquements et
la direction s'en défend elle le
président américain doit se rendre sur
place demain les explications de notre
correspondant aux états unis thomas
bonnin
après les violentes tornades qui ont
frappé les etats-unis ce week-end
l'heure est désormais aux questions
notamment autour d'un entrepôt qui
appartient à amazon et qui est située
dans l'état de l'illinois où six
personnes sont décédées
assez vite finalement il ya eu des
interrogations sur les conditions à
l'intérieur du bâtiment écouter quand
vous allez parler à amazon vous ont-ils
parlé du fait qu'ils ont conduit les
employés dans un endroit sûr il y
avait-il un endroit où il pouvait
s'abriter
nous n'avons pas parlé spécifiquement du
mouvement des employés
mais comme je les dis je les ai imploré
de soutenir cette communauté et ils ont
proposé de le faire
et depuis il ya des témoignages qui
jette le trouble sur le rôle et
l'attitude des dirigeants de cet
entrepôt est la façon avec laquelle ils
ont géré les événements par exemple
l'une des conjointes à d'une des six
victimes de cet entrepôt affirme que son
conjoint justement n'a pas été autorisé
à quitter les lieux autre interrogation
elle concerne la politique d'amazon qui
consiste à interdire l'usagé du
téléphone portable sur le lieu de
travail ce qui ne mesure qui est
aujourd'hui contestée parce que c'est
avec le téléphone portable que les
salariés sont en mesure de recevoir les
alertes d'urgence comme par exemple un
avertissement avant le passage d'une
tornade alors amazon répond en affirmant
que les salariés de cet entrepôt de
l'illinois avait leur téléphone et que
tout a été fait pour les mettre à l'abri
et les placer en sécurité une enquête a
toutefois été ouverte par l' agence
fédérale compétente en matière de santé
au travail elle devra statuer sur le
respect ou non des normes en la matière
dans cet entrepôt
puis critiqué pour sa réaction tardive
le pdg d'amazon jeff bezos a finalement
adressé un message de compassion pour
les victimes sur twitter amazon qui a
également annoncé le versement d'une
aide d'un million de dollars à la ville
où était basé son entrepôt